i'm gonna try and curve this when i'm
end up in another lane
look at that oh
that was perfect hey i'm kiki hernandez
of the boston red sox i'm about to check
out a few spots around town with a
little help from my wells fargo active
cash visa card which earns me unlimited
two percent cash rewards on purchases
let's do it
[Music]
this is my first year in new city so i
like to go around and explore every time
that i can hi i'm here for a game and a
pair of shoes coming from la i wanted to
go to a market where i was going to get
the chance to play every day on a
winning team and it was a perfect
opportunity to get a fresh start here in
boston and build a winning team again in
a city that's so passionate about their
sports
i thought we were a lucky strike but
there's no strike happening not even
getting lucky
took a little break here to say what's
up to some fans hey what's up man
i was just wondering
it's been great so far
thank you so much for everything you're
doing
thank you man thank you i appreciate it
i want to go i want to go sneaker
shopping where should i go i would say
now you're in boston
i'm here at bodega let's check out some
sneakers and see what they got i have a
lot of shoes i don't think my wife is
happy with the amount of shoes that i
have considering it takes more than one
closet but we're working on it i get her
some shoes as well do i want to go with
lifestyle do i want to go sporty
let me try these off
feel good i think i found the ones all
right i'm all set man perfect whenever
you're ready you can just go right at
the top
one of my favorite things to do in new
cities is to look for authentic puerto
rican food and here we are at veganthis
here is the best puerto rican food in
town so let's check it out
i don't necessarily have a favorite
puerto rican food but rice and beans
with any meat and i love my food i love
my roots and for me to be able to
represent puerto rico when i go out on
the field it means a lot to me it was a
lot of fun getting to know boston a
little better today and with my active
cash card i earn two percent cash
rewards on purchases whether i'm bowling
or grabbing a bite to eat i will catch
you guys later